>>Peter Fortenbaugh: Alright, good afternoon
everybody.
My name's Peter Fortenbaugh.
I'm executive director of the Boys and Girls
Clubs of Peninsula and I wanna thank you for
having us here today.
A special thanks to David Lawee who arranged
it.
I really appreciate it and Patty and Cindy
for doing all this and Cliff behind the scenes
for making this possible.
So thank you very much.
As I was coming here today I was thinking
about Google and the Boys and Girls Clubs
and I realized that we actually have a very
fundamentally shared value, or fundamentally
shared important value which is the idea of
creating opportunities for everybody and making
the world more flat and creating opportunities
for people who maybe used to be disenfranchised.
And you think about Google's mission to really
democratize information and to make information
available to people that it didn't used to
be so they now have opportunities that didn't
used to be possible.
At the Boys and Girls Club, our vision is
for all of our youth to grow up to become
self sufficient adults.
Now there's a challenge there because today,
right here in the heart of Silicon Valley,
just four miles from where we're sitting,
over half the kids are dropping out of high
school and that's the challenge that we face
at the Boys and Girls Clubs, that's the problem
that we're addressing, that we're trying to
solve.
We do that through two ways, the first step
we have is to bring our members in to track
the youth and provide them a sense of belonging
and to give them a place where they can be
safe, have relationships with adults and really
get a sense that someone cares about them
and they belong.
The second thing we do is we help instill
in them, help them develop, the academic and
life skills they need to thrive.
So I thought what we'd do today is share with
you some of the stories of some of our amazing
members so you can hear from them directly
how growing up in circumstances that are very
challenging, they've persevered, they thrived
and they've really developed the skills required
to be successful and are amazing, amazing
young men and women.
So, before they actually speak we're gonna
show a video that was created by a teen in
Redwood City, it's a partnership with Adobe
as well as the Black Eyed Peas and the Peapod
Academy.
And this is a video and a song that our teen
created, wrote themselves and I think it gives
you a good insight into their lives and where
they're, where they see themselves breaking
a pattern and becoming very successful.
This is called "Be the Difference."
[Music plays]
>>Lyrics: I am the difference.
Future lookin' bright green.
There's nobody like me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference.
I take the lead.
You can get beside me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference.
Future lookin' bright green.
There's nobody like me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference.
I take the lead.
You can get beside me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference.
Poverty, the issue of the ages, you and I
can change this, we write the pages.
Homeless sleepin' on the street, layin' on
the concrete shiverin' to death cause they
can't afford some socks on they feet.
A random act of kindness can help cure the
blindness.
We need to be the voice cause it's time to
break the silence.
You and I can save them.
We don't need to blame them.
Pray to God to give us strength, in Jesus
name, Amen.
You can be the greatest, education makes you
greater.
More knowledge, more ways to get paper, flawless,
yeah, straight out of college, now that's
the real definition of ballin'.
And average of 32 percent graduate, the percentage
of dropouts, 68.
All you gotta do stay in school stay focused.
You can be a part of 32 and you know.
I am the difference.
Future lookin' bright green.
There's nobody like me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference.
I take the lead.
You can get beside me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference.
Future lookin' bright green.
There's nobody like me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference.
I take the lead.
You can get beside me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference.
On the streets a place where you're brutalized,
it says in the Bible that God had already
visualized his sons and daughters on planet
earth with transgression.
Livin' on the street but they could never
confess it.
Now it's time to change the hood and how we
livin', I'm the change in my neighborhood
always stand above it.
Murder rates decreased, now increase the peace.
If you down with the change then follow me.
All I see is is guys with gang signs on they
chest tryin' follow up they older brother's
ghetto footsteps.
I'm gonna tell you like this do you and no
one else, try to set a good example to those
who need help and just know you ain't alone
you got family that got your back, see I'm
a role model keepin' my young bros on track.
Yeah, I'm a changed man but you can call me
the difference, a role model quick to teach
you in an instant.
I am the difference, future lookin' bright
green.
There's nobody like me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference, I take the lead.
You can get beside me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference, future lookin' bright
green.
There's nobody like me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference, I take the lead.
You can get beside me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference.
Nobody can hold us down you know, you know,
you know.
Nobody can hold us back you know, you know.
They don't believe in me but that's a steamin'
me, the motivation that keeps me on the feet.
That's because the difference is me.
I am the difference, future lookin' bright
green.
There's nobody like me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference, I take the lead.
You can get beside me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference, future lookin' bright
green.
There's nobody like me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference, I take the lead.
You can get beside me.
Know what I'm sayin'?
I am the difference.
[Music plays]
>>Peter Fortenbaugh: So hopefully that gives
you a sense of the emotional energy that's
created at the Boys and Girls Clubs.
You saw some footage there from a Redwood
City clubhouse where a lot of our members,
who are here today, recorded that.
And that sense of belonging they get and such
a purpose that they get with our programs.
Next up I'd like to introduce our youth of
the year from 2011, last year, this is Ms.
Nancy Orosio who's gonna share with you her
story about being a member at the Boys and
Girls Clubs.
[Applause]
>>Nancy Orosio: Thank you.
So, good evening, I'm sorry, good afternoon
everyone I'm Nancy.
I am currently a sophomore attending Santa
Clara University.
I graduated from Sacred Heart Preparatory
in Atherton in 2011 and, I'm studying political
science.
So Peter asked me if I could come here and
share my story with you and, in reality, I
had no idea what I was supposed to talk about
because my story entails a lot of different,
I would say, aspects and so I'm gonna go ahead
and give you a very raw, like, outline of
the things I've been through and where I'm
going from there.
I'm the oldest of three children.
I am born to immigrant parents.
I was born in Mexico and I came to the US
when I was 11 months old, so I've grown up
here since.
I know no other home and I grew up with my
mom as my biggest mentor and neither of my
parents finished middle school.
So that gives you an idea of how much guidance
I had in terms of what education looked like.
And my mother whom didn't finish seventh grade
kept telling, "You need to go to school and
you need to graduate from High School and
you need to go to college and you're gonna
be whatever you wanna be when you grow up
as long as you work hard and as long as you
stay in school."
Now, those words meant something that I didn't
really grasp the meaning of at the time and
now I know that they've made all the difference
in the world because when you have parents
that care, you have a foundation set for you.
And that is something that I was very lucky
to have that a lot of my friends in the community
that you saw in the video, didn't have.
I had parents who cared and I had parents
who pushed me and who believed that even though
they didn't speak English and even though
they didn't have an education themselves,
they could provide me with something that
they weren't able, they didn't have the opportunity
to.
So when I was in middle school I remember
going to school and talking to friends and
our, I think the one thing that we looked
forward was always after school because we
would hang out and go do maybe things that
we weren't supposed to do and that was the
best time of our day.
It wasn't really being in school and it wasn't
really being about th-, sorry, thinking about
college or thinking about what we wanted to
do as a career.
I was very lucky because I was lured into
the Boys and Girls Club and there I found
people who talked about college and talked
about a career and talked about an education
and how you could be someone in the world
and how you could be a difference and how
you could change the world but it took a lot
of support and it took a lot of people for
me to realize what that meant.
And I thought it was really cool that you
could be a leader in your community but I
didn't really know what that looked like.
And I thought that I could change the world
but I didn't know how I wanted to do that.
So my mentors, Tracy being one of them, were
really crucial and I'm talking about mentors
including my mom and the Boys and Girls Club
and at school because, essentially, even though
I had it in me and even though I had the desire
I wouldn’t have, I wouldn't have gotten
to college if it wasn't for them and I wouldn't
have got to Sacred Heart.
So, basically, I grew up in a place where
gangs, drugs, alcohol and graffiti were an
everyday thing.
You would see it everywhere, you would see
it in your friends, in your family and it
was kind of like the norm.
And very few people were even expected to
graduate from high school and even middle
school.
I had a cousin and a friend who never graduated
from middle school.
So if high school was the objective some people
didn't even get there.
So, lucky for me, as I mentioned earlier,
I got to the Boys and Girls Club and I applied
to Sacred Heart and when I got to Sacred Heart
I thought that was one of the biggest accomplishments,
going to a private Catholic school.
But then I realized that the expectations
there were very different than in my neighborhood.
In my neighborhood, if you graduated from
middle school you were cool, you were alright,
you were set ,whereas, at Sacred Heart it
was about getting to an Ivy League school,
something that had never even crossed my mind.
It took a lot of people for me to realize
that I could do it and sometimes, as much
as I wanted to, I didn't see the path.
I had to reach out to other people to remind
me what it took and it takes hard work, it
takes my mother's encouragement, it takes
an organization like the Boys and Girls Club
and it takes, basically, people to believe
in you, because I was not very different than
my friends in middle school.
I was not special, I was not smarter, I was
not any richer, I didn't have anything other
than my mother and people who cared about
me and that was what made a difference for
me.
And I think my best friend in middle school,
who now has two babies, could have had the
same opportunities that I did but she didn't
because circumstances were different for her
and she didn't have a support network like
the Boys and Girls Club.
She didn't have a mom who cared and who would
tell her you can do anything in the world
if you only go to school.
So, I guess where I'm going with this is that
you don't have to be rich, you don't have
to be superwoman to make a difference in someone's
life.
You only need some time, commitment and that's
all that it took for me because I realized
that the people that I grew up with had very
little faith in themselves.
And sometimes when you don't have faith in
yourself it takes someone else to tell you,
you can do it, and I had that.
I had that and I also had the desire, meaning,
because I saw how hard my parents grew up.
And seeing my mom be a housekeeper and my
dad a construction worker coming home everyday
really late made me realize that I didn't
want a future like that for myself and my
own children.
And that was one of the things that, that
really drove me to stay at Sacred Heart, do
the work that it required and to get to Santa
Clara.
Now, it wasn't easy and especially because
I didn't have parents with an education, I
didn't have parents who knew how to navigate
an education sys-, the education system but
I asked for help.
And I asked for tutors and I asked for mentors
and I asked, I asked people to help me because
I cared and because they seemed to care for
me as well.
And one of the things that one of my mentors
once told me was that educating and mentoring
a child like me was not only an investment
of time in me but it was an investment in
a community and when you dedicate time to
one child you're making a difference, not
only in one person's life but you're also
making a difference in a community.
So I hope that leaves you with a little bit
of something to think about and that you feel
a little compelled to come to the Boys and
Girls Club and to mentor children or to find
someone who is willing to do the work that
it requires to be successful.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>>Peter Fortenbaugh: Now I'd like to share
the story or the voice of one of the Boys
and Girls Clubs staff.
At the Boys and Girls Clubs we serve about
1,100 kids every single day about 1,800 kids
come at least 50 times or more a year, basically
around once a week across nine different locations
all in East Palo Alto, Eastern Menlo Park
and unincorporated part of Redwood City.
So we have about 180 employees who work with
us 45 full time and about 135 or so part time.
The employees are really, the staff is really
where the magic happens because what we do
with the youth, folks like Nancy, it's not
about a new program, it's not about a new
technology, it's about relationships.
And the only way you can really help these
young people achieve their potential is by
connecting with them and they have to trust
you.
And it's only through a meaningful relationship
that that can happen.
So the most important thing for us at the
Boys and Girls Clubs is having the right staff
and I'm gonna introduce the woman Miss Cherie
Kabba who runs our computer club house in
East Palo Alto.
She's absolutely one of our star staff because
she's an amazing technologist, she could be
working here at Google if she wanted to, she
knows everything about technology there is
to know but even more importantly she's a
kid magnet and you'll know why.
And she gets the kids and they get her and
she's able to use the technology but then
more importantly has a relationship to influence
the kids in East Palo Alto community, to stay
in school, to make the right choices.
So I'd like to ask Miss Chillin to come share
her perspective of why she's a Boys and Girls
Club staff person.
[Applause]
>>Cherie Kabba: Thank you very much.
I am Cherie Kabba.
The kids call me Miss Chillin', my stage name
is Chillin the conscious poet.
I'm a retired poet, been on stage 25 years
and I like to think that I work for one of
the most amazing nonprofit organizations in
the country.
And the reason why I say that is not cause
of the awesome staff but it's because of the
kids.
This is the fourth state that I've lived in,
California.
The community that I work in, East Palo Alto,
reflects the community that I come from in
inner city Chicago and I'm just really blessed
to have the opportunity to share the space
with them.
I believe nothing happens by mistake and so
I'm there for a reason and I'm there till
the Creator tells me that it's time to leave.
So I wanna share with you a story.
I was sittin in a meeting with my supervisors,
Michael Jones and, of course, Peter Fortenbaugh
and he asked me one question.
He said, "Why do you do what you do in the
ICC?" and my response is simple, "I love my
J-O-B" You see, I teach the youth to fall
in love with technology, metaphorically, I
play cupid and my arrow is imagery.
Please allow me to explain.
In the stages of infancy even a craftsman
chooses a topic to study and develops a disciplined
of mastery.
You see, in truth, I lure the young people
in the ICC by bringing life to originality
then secretly I teach them how to increase
their vocabulary through spoken words.
I curb their appetite of profanity with new
phrases and verses of opportunities.
I find other ways than scrolls and lily pads
to tell stories of struggles of not having
a dad.
We color inside the lines with the fine tunings
of rhythm and rhymes.
I am a modern day griot and I combine the
West African traditions with our initiatives
and missions.
That village in the Proverbs that they speak
of to raise a family is calling us to a higher
place of creativity.
You see, this J-O-B allows me to be me.
And when the Most High has given you the gift
to work with babies there's no time for complacency.
You gotta bring ya "A" game to the table with
lots of energy.
There's no clock to punch cause a 9 to 5 is
unheard of when paid by salary.
And if the truth were told, there's no dollar
amount or silver and gold that could compensate
me for my competency.
I don't do this for the money and I don't
do this just to be doin' something, see, as
a matter of fact, I don't have one but two
Master's degrees but humbly I share my story
to explain what I do is not for everybody.
At a young age my purpose was spelled out
for me combining spoken word and technology
is why I'm here, see.
Case and point remember now, I play cupid
and Alfi, a young man I shot with imagery,
he enters my department daily.
His afternoons begins with givin' me a hug
and then briefly he brings life to his truths
with sincerity.
I listen intently as his non verbal speak
directly and though I am exploring the possibilities
of how to capture this moment with Adobe and
how not to exploit but to document his story,
his words are spoken with vitality and by
the time he takes a breath and begins to breathe
freely
[Takes a deep breath]
>>Cherie Kabba: in one hand I placed a camera,
in the other a tri P-O-D.
You see, Alfi now has my media crew and my
quest to continue this journey is never complete
cause the reality of this J-O-B is it's not
a job but a lifestyle for myself and others
like me and it is my responsibility to my
ancestors to carry the oral traditions until
infinity.
Now, don't get all caught up in this delivery
cause for a couple of decades I been doin'
me.
Don't mistake my words for hustle and flows,
aint no pimp in me, just L-O-V-E.
And until technology is mandatory universally
my quest will forever be incomplete.
So Pete, increasing literacy via technology
is why I do what I do in the ICC.
Thank you.
[Applause]
[Cheering]
>>Peter Fortenbaugh: Ms. Chillin', unbelievable.
That's why I go to work every day.
Fantastic.
Now I'd like to ask two of our fine young
gentlemen from the Redwood City Clubhouse
are gonna come up and share their stories.
So [Lalo Salvadra] and Diamante Horton are
two of our Peapod Academy music stars and
they're gonna share their story and then after
they share their story we're gonna be treated
to another song, another video and then a
live song they're gonna sing for us.
Lalo, you first.
>> [Jose Salvadra]: So, thank you Peter.
My name is [Jose Salvadra].
I'm 19 years old and I am currently enrolled
in Cosway Polytechnical College and I am a
former member of the Boys and Girls Club of
the Peninsula, Mervin G. Morris Clubhouse
to be specific.
I first became involved with the club about
3 and a half years ago.
I was really interested in music as a child
and also in high school and I began experimenting
with music at home just free downloadable
software, actually creating the music and
I showed one of my projects to one of my friends
not knowing that she was a member of the Boys
and Girls Club.
So when she heard it she told me, she was
like, "Oh, well you should come to the Boys
and Girls Club" and I was like, "Well, what's
at the Boys and Girls Club?
Isn't it just like a place to take your kids
to babysit?" and she was like, "No, you know,
they have a music studio, they have a bunch
of other programs and it's very teen oriented
unlike what most people think."
And a lot of people did think that it was
like a place to babysit kids and so as soon
as she mentioned the studio I was like, "Oh,
you know, I've been dying to get the experience
to be in an actual professional studio, what
the environments like."
So I went and as soon as I walked in everyone
was welcoming me, "Oh, hello how you doing?
What's your name?
Oh, I'm so and so."
So I was just like, "Wow, you don't even know
me why are you talking to me?"
So I spent the whole day there and I really
enjoyed my time there and I was like, "Wow,
these people are asking about me and they
don't even know who I am.
They actually showed interest to find out
who I am, what I do."
So, you know, over time I started going once,
twice a week, three times a week, four times
a week, I was there all week, they had to
start kicking me out when it was closing time
and I would always be in the studio.
Now at this time I had just lost somebody.
A dear friend of mine who I grew up with and
I really didn't know how to deal with it and
then this was prior to joining the Boys and
Girls Club so I was kind of lost, didn't really
know where to go, my personal life suffered
dearly as well as my academics.
But, being at the Boys and Girls Club really,
really, they really showed me that support
because, like, I'd go in daylight in the studio
and I'd come out, like, and it was already
dark.
I started joining other programs such as the
Keystone program and the College Bound program.
And the Boys and Girls Club found out that
I wasn't doing so hot with my academics and
this is what really drew me in is that they're
very academic based so they said, "If you
don't get your grades right you can't go into
the studio."
So, me being me, I was like, "No, I have to
be in the studio."
So that gave me an incentive, they found my
weak point and they made it my forte and I
started working and I started working on my
academics, my grades increased and, you know,
I was just very involved and, you know, kept
me out of trouble.
A couple years passed by, graduation's coming
up and, you know, there was that support,
you know, "You got this.
You're gonna graduate."
And with all my involvement, all the events,
just all my involvement with the Boys and
Girls Club I was able to unknowingly build
a portfolio for myself.
So this is what ultimately, you know, led
me to college and now what I plan to do is,
within a year and a half, obtain my Bachelor's
degree and further pursue a Master's degree
in music business and production and entrepreneurship
and what I wanna do is just take everything
that the Boys and Girls Club did for me, through
the obstacles that I came over the past few
years and I wanna be able to give back and
give back the same feeling, the same positivity,
the same difference in the community that
they gave to me, to somebody else, for the
next generation.
[Applause]
>>Diamante Horton: Hello.
I'm Diamante Horton.
I was born in Portland, Oregon and then I
had moved down to Washington and then down
to California, Redwood City and then I moved
to Patterson but between all that I kept a
real strong bond with the Redwood City Boys
and Girls Club.
I was raised in a low income family.
I was living in like an apartment, like one
bedroom.
My mother slept on the floor and she gave
me the mattress.
I was like so broke, so young that I didn't
notice what rich or what wealthy or a middle
class family looked like I just thought I
was, I just thought I had it all.
I was real happy with just nothing.
Let me see, when I was in third grade my mother
had, she didn't want me out on the streets
so she had signed me up for the Boys and Girls
Club but out of rebellion I would just, like,
leave, I would just skip Boys and Girls Club.
I did that all the way to middle school and
I'm a real shy person but ironically I was
with an outgoing crowd that was really up
to no good.
I've been like firsthand witness to drug abuse
and just a lot of violence, gang violence,
gang affiliation, shootings; break ins, just
like it's a real twisted life.
Like your own sister's, like, a sex slave
and it's just crazy.
Like, you're not, you're not, I don't know,
you're just not a kid.
Like everyone would look at you and be like,
"Oh, there's this kid" like things happen
in your mind.
Like, it just changes your perspective of
life so I didn't really feel like I had a
path to go anywhere.
So one day, since I wouldn't, I was shy so
I wouldn't speak a lot I would just start
writing.
I wrote lyrics because I didn't know how to,
I didn't know how to ask for help, I didn't
know, I didn't know if I should say anything
so I just wrote lyrics and that was my outlet,
I felt better.
Pretty soon, like, in a matter of minutes
it became an obsession, it was like my drug,
I needed to write lyrics.
I used to fill notebooks up, front and back
just one page a night or something, maybe
two.
And then my, I went back, my mother had signed
up my siblings for the Boys and Girls Club,
so I went back, one day I went to go pick
up my sister and I had seen they had a music
studio and I was like, "Oh man.
I need to look at that."
So I signed up, I went back to the Boys and
Girls Club as a member.
I got into the music.
My grades were really low and they were like,
"You need to have at least a 2.5 to be able
to use the music equipment" and, you know,
my grades just shot up.
Like, I was, like all throughout my academic
years my teachers would say, "You know, your
son might have to repeat my grade."
Like every year the teacher would tell my
mom that your son might have to repeat my
class and my mom was just so worried.
So that was cool how they were like, "Yeah,
you gotta do well" and they had tutors, they
had, they had everything you need.
So they really helped me.
I went from that shy kid with that street
life to; I traded all that in for the knowledge
of music and to pave a better road to positivity.
So now I'm attending Cogswell Polytechnical
College in Sunnyvale, double majoring in audio
engineering and entrepreneurship and I just
wanna say that even, not even your friends
can try to persuade, what do I wanna say,
not even people around you could be a negative
influence, you know, you have to take it upon
yourself to choose the right path.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>>Peter Fortenbaugh: I'd like to share with
you one other video.
It's called Vision 20/20 and this video came
about when President Obama declared and initiative
for America to have the most college graduates
per capita of any country since we've fallen
so far behind.
And then Adobe, one of our major partners,
reached out to us and asked us if we would
create a video to capture the importance of
education.
And originally we were gonna show this video,
create this video just for the Bay Area Tour,
just for the Bay Area visit but then they
saw this video and it was so successful, they
liked it so much, they used it across country.
And then it was so great and performed by
these gentlemen here that they actually got
to fly out to Washington D.C. to perform it
at Howard University with Arne Duncan at a
conference.
So just to give you a flavor, Arne Duncan
is the Secretary of Education.
So, you know, Lalo mentioned earlier how the
Boys and Girls Club has a perception of just
being a place for kids to hang out and certainly
kids do hang out there and there's an element
of daycare with the Boys and Girls Club but
it's so much more than that.
And we really have evolved dramatically over
the last five years becoming much more of
a learning center and much more of an extended
learning day program in partnership with schools
and families.
And we now run programs, not only in our three
clubhouses, but at six school sites on campus.
We partner very closely with principals, superintendents,
teachers and really make sure that our curriculum
is an extension of the school day and so that
the teacher looks at it as really having a
school that goes from 8 in the morning until
6 at night as opposed to an add on school.
And I think that this video will address that
and give you a flavor of the role of education.
So, this is Vision 20/20.
[Music plays]
>>Lyrics: 20/20 vision, wear my cap and gown.
We can see our futures taking off the ground.
20/20 vision never been so clear, on the road
to success great futures start here.
Just imagine if our education system was better.
Do you think everybody would treat school
like whatever?
Nah.
Surprise, surprise the more knowledge, more
better, see we are the naked birds and education
is the feathers.
Yeah, what if every education in the world
was the same and private schools didn't cost
money so we wouldn't pay.
See, every mother and father wants their children
to learn.
Without a fair chance money gets hard to earn.
What if all teachers cared and didn't compare
the color, the race or the clothes that we
wear?
And wouldn't be scared of all of them problems
that we shared.
Many open wounds throughout our whole life
we bared, listen.
I got a plan, no more weapons of mass destruction;
still we help education succeed and watch
this plan function.
[Cannot understand] lights shinin' from down
below this is our idea, it's up to ya'll to
make it grow.
What if our fathers never left us when times
got hard?
What if our mothers always told us we could
shoot for the stars?
What if our brothers fight for literacy instead
of the hood?
What if our sisters understood being smart
looks good?
What if you lead by example and pave the way?
A clear path for my siblings, I hope they
stay, I hope they open their eyes to a brighter
day and greater future to come is impossible
to fail with faith.
Cause knowledge is power and power is love
and love is a family only sent from above.
You can't rely on the system alone; we need
a family support to make education a part
of our home.
Part of our home.
>>male #1: I need advice from my parents.
>>female #1: I need my independence.
>>female #2: As parents we need give a lot
of love and encouragement to our children
in order for them to be successful in school.
>>female #3: Family needs to be more involved
academically with their children.
>>male #2: Remember the most important job
is the one at home.
>>female #4: I need encouragement and support
from my mom.
>>female #5: I think the best way to support
our kids is to communicate with them and just
check and verify their work and make sure
they stay on track.
>>Lyrics: Sex Ed can't be given but definitely
taken.
We makin' staircases so you step up and take
it.
Knowledge be my transportation, motivation
got us racin'.
Communities, a pile of leaves and congregation
must be rakin'.
Think about dropouts and seats that remain
vacant.
It's just precious education wasted.
What's goin' on with the subject?
What's next I ask myself what if?
What if?
What if we excel in persistence and decisions
cause it takes a village just for one to be
risen.
I can pinpoint what everybody else's eyes
are missin'.
I can see a bright future comin', 20/20 vision.
20/20 vision, wear my cap and gown.
We can see our futures takin' off the ground.
20/20 vision's never been so clear.
We're on the road to success, great futures
start here.
20/20 vision, wear my cap and gown.
We can see our future takin' off the ground.
Takin' off the ground.
[Music plays]
>>Peter Fortenbaugh: So the only way that
we can possibly top that is with a live performance
today from our three stars.
So I'd ask Diamante and Lalo to join us back
again and PJ's gonna join them up here as
well with a little guitar and they're gonna
perform a song that they've written just for,
just for this afternoon.
So this is a premier of their new song.
[Guitar playing]
>>Lyrics: Close your eyes.
Try to imagine what it's like to be tossed
into this world alone and broken inside.
To have life beat you senseless and still
expect you to thrive.
Now picture tryin' to take flight with clipped
wings as your dreams whisper in your ear beggin'
you to fly.
You take a breath, you clear your mind and
with all odds against you somehow you manage
to rise.
I know it's crazy, right?
You might be wonderin' if I'm the one that
this message applies to.
Well you're right but this isn't just a story.
This is my life, let's take a walk down memory
lane, just see what I see.
I grew up with no money; I'm humble with a
lot of pride.
Came up from nothing, from the bottom I climbed.
I didn't know until the world it opened my
eyes.
At 15 I lost someone for the very first time.
[Guitar playing]
>>Lyrics: And let's not mention I was exposed
to drugs in junior high.
Exposed to all the violence surrounding our
community with positive unity was something
that you couldn't find.
Where safety was an issue and violence was
a pride, yo, I felt my momma's pain every
time I saw her cry and I felt my father's
stress from workin' late night overtime.
So I take these liabilities and turn them
into allies to make a change.
But I see one digit when I'm in the bank.
I see one digit when I'm in the bank.
Yeah, but I see one digit when I'm in the
bank.
Mixed emotions make it hard to think, make
it hard to think.
Yeah.
Lord forbid I fall from the agony that it
brings.
Blind to accessories and ice and the gadgets.
Now without it I ball like Dwight from the
Magics, overkill, that means I barely see
the mattress comin' from the wrong road to
see right where the path is.
Allen Poe wrote some crow thinkin' like psychopathic,
empty stomach tryin to stick a flashlight
through the cabinets.
Silence [cannot understand] so I'm fightin'
all these classes.
I be up and down the wings takin' flight throughout
the campus.
Tryin' to picture life's moments with a light
between cameras, shadows around me only emphasize
what has happened.
[Guitar playing]
>>Lyrics: Tryin' to be where I traveled then
you might need an atlas.
But I could prob'ly take you there.
The past is the past just to make it here.
Make it clear.
You know what I've been through just to make
it here.
You know how much I make in a year?
You prolly don't wanna take it there.
I'm talkin' EBT's and empty kitchens there's
only one way you can get it.
One lick away from riches, yeah.
Who are you when you get your plate from someone
else because behind that mask you know you
someone else?
I'm free fallin' with nothin' to catch the
fall and even when you have nothin' they expect
you give your all and the way I float these
folks think we in the same boat but nope.
See, it's more like an abandoned ship.
It's a different ball game with no ref around
but somehow I managed to make it to the championship.
Thank you.
[Guitar playing]
[Applause]
>>Peter Fortenbaugh: Alright.
Thank you so much.
That was a first time premier you just heard
right there.
So the last thing we just wanna mention today
is how you can get involved.
How, what kind of support we could use to
help these amazing young people and others
like them graduate from high school ready
for college and career.
There are four ways that you can get involved.
First, advocate, people don't know about the
Boys and Girls Clubs.
If they've heard about it they think we're
a place that kids hang out, a swim in gym,
nice daycare, come by and visit, bring some
friends, bring some peers, check it out.
You'll see things that'll amaze you I'm confident
and you'll meet some amazing, amazing young
people.
Spread the word.
Number two, we gotta pay the bills, we always
love financial support.
You kinda get that one.
Number three is help with exposure.
We really need to help with exposure and provide
opportunities for these kids.
You know, so many kids today in Silicon Valley
get their resume built by doing free summer
jobs, free internships, right?
They get their foot in the door.
Maybe their Dad or Uncle works at Google and
gets them a job at YouTube or something like
that.
That's kind of how it works a lot of times
these days.
Well, not everyone has those opportunities.
You have an internship this summer, I can
think of four fantastic candidates, really
close that'd be willing to interview.
So could you host a fieldtrip?
You know a lot of these folks in our clubs
that grow up not knowing what some basic jobs
are.
You know, all of our members know what rap
stars are or basketball stars are but do they
know what a Google engineer does?
Or a Google tech guy?
How about a Google person in office services?
How about a Google chef?
You know, right here at Google you have pretty
much every occupation that's ever been created,
a masseuse, dry cleaning, I don't know, I
can't imagine, car mechanics.
You know, bring some of our members over here
for a field trip.
Help expose them.
And then lastly, fourthly, volunteer.
If you have any time, any opportunity or any
friends that are interested, come spend time
at the clubs.
You heard the story from Nancy early on about
how she was influenced by some positive voices,
some positive, she found some positive influences
in her life.
All of our members need that.
We have 1,900 members who come at least 50
times a year, we need 1,900 mentors.
So come by, check us out, we're open till
8 o'clock at night.
So you can work half a Google day, leave at
6, we're literally four miles away, right?
You can stay off the 101 just take East Bay
Shore, go right up and you'll be there and
you can volunteer from 6:30 to 8 and then
you can come back and start the second half
of your day.
Or bring them here for dinner, whatever, there's
lots of great opportunities.
So that's the Boys and Girls Clubs.
I wanna thank you so much for having us here,
David and his team and Patty.
If anyone has any questions for either me
or more interestingly any of our kids we'd
be happy to take them.
Otherwise just thank you so much for having
us here today.
[Applause]